there's also jobs out there 100 that
are the same job and yet one like a man
will be paid more and a woman will be
paid less yeah
I've worked in one if you want to know
what was the job well I was a lifeguard
okay
um so um when you when you were applying
for the job did you apply for the job
like on the job board like indeed or
something like that no I had worked as a
lifeguard for three years and then I
switched working place and then I
learned the other person that had less
experience than me he was the man he
earned about three quid more
um anyway and did you when you ask when
you see lifeguard that's that's a very
nice
um example because I would think that
um
the point I'm trying to make anyways is
when you apply for any job role
is there do you see well like if you say
you want to become a lifeguard for
instance and you see it on indeed do you
see
um lifeguard role women's salary 10
pounds an hour men's salary 15 pounds an
hour or do you see lifeguard rule 10
pounds an hour and whoever gets hired
gets that salary it usually says from
depending on experience or something
like that well okay then then that would
come to negotiation power that has
nothing to do with sex um well my other
question is why don't we talk about the
women models get paid more than male
models where is everyone where is the
marches
right so one causes the cost so the
reason why that women and it works the
other way around too so the reason why
women don't tend to be in male dominated
Industries as much is just because it's
unpleasant it's saying for the reason
why men don't women women don't want to
do hard jobs no okay do you think a
veterinarian is a hard joke
I mean you can find some Niche like
primaries you can find some Niche Fringe
things it's like way but the number one
employers of women is it's teachers and
nurses yes because that's how it's
always been and you're right correct
what is the hardest jobs the ones that
have the most workplace deaths men do
them so it makes sense that they're paid
you're defining hard by simply are you
more likely to die which is about the
dark way
okay you don't think a job is harder to
do if you might die doing it to be fair
you can die if you work in a hospital to
be fair you might catch up I mean you
can but it's it's not as likely as I as
that American job to deal with animals
they're pretty unpredictable right why
person let's go into vets one percent of
um vets are women double okay
so it's 60 it's so it's still close to
15. no it's over 60 I said double so
it's like okay
I just was expecting like because in the
industries I mentioned it's like 95 men
it's not close to 50 50. you don't think
you've got two-thirds I don't I don't
think that's the same as 95 I think men
have been working for a lot longer than
women I mean so I think women are still
trying to come into their fields you
know there's some women that are still
reliant on men some women are still
reliant on their parents even you know
there's women that are in their 20s and
they're still relying that's just an
excuse if you were born today you have
no barriers there are absolutely that's
fine but in regards to like trying to
move up and trying to get further in
your career not just getting to a career
entry level it can be difficult quotas
they literally pay companies to hire
women but do you realize the older
Generations haven't died yet so you're
going to need to give it a couple
Generations before we can actually judge
it I mean it's going to be more older
people that's that's just such a car
back the older generation wants to make
money if you're telling me you you tell
a 55 year old dude you get money to hire
women you don't think he's gonna hire
more women now that's know what I mean I
mean until the older generation have
died where there is still inequality
because obviously if you're going past
60 years old all those women that are
that old still have the same mindset
that they had because they didn't have I
mean from where from what era like how
old are you talking like my like my
mom's like the Equal Pay Gap the Equal
Pay Act was it was in 1964. I'm talking
about opportunities from going to
University so it's going to be 1963 was
the equal it's been illegal it is
illegal to pay women less than men this
young lady's already given an example
that she's been underpaid and this was
before this was after the 60s
and it's still an example
other examples
and I have examples where I've got paid
more like than a guy could I could I
just ask what did you say you're a
doctor right yes
what is yours dance on this and
especially in the hospital like because
obviously we're talking about nurses and
Etc so I just wanted to know what you
it's it's difficult I mean you know
clearly the majority of doctors at the
moment are male that's mainly because of
the older Generations the majority of
medical students and young doctors are
female sort of switched around and that
part of that's part of the reason this
is so complicated is because we're often
measuring people of different
Generations so I honestly don't know I
think probably
from anecdotes from my own experience
from my reading of the data there are
ways that women get screwed over in the
job market than men the men don't there
will be some the other way around I
don't know who is worse off overall and
I it's almost a red herring because the
question was does this mean that men
can't have an opinion on abortion I just
think
what do you think
you think you know there's so many
things to say about this one was I used
to be a fetus which I think is important
one is I might have my own kids one day
you know this feature some of the
fetuses this might be mine hopefully not
that many because I only have one wife
who's next to me
um
what I really think is you know when we
think about Justice and when we think
about having a community that works
together in a society that functions we
have to have men and women talking to
each other giving their best to each
other
and working in harmony right so take an
example Emma Watson's campaign he for
she that was basically saying for
women's equality we cannot just do this
with women alone men have to use
whatever platform they might have we can
debate whether they have it whatever
privilege they might have men have to
use it to fight for equality now the way
I think that links to abortion is
firstly that I think the pro-life view
is about equality for the child as well
saying the child has an equal right to
life so everyone has a duty to fight for
that but at the same time what really
gets me about this is
think about before abortion was
legalized if a man gets a woman pregnant
the likelihood is they get married
suddenly some of those marriages don't
work out I admit but many of them do the
man provides for the child the man
provides for the woman and the man has
that sense of responsibility now what
happens when abortion is legal
the man can suddenly have sex with
whoever he wants and when she gets
pregnant he says it's your body it's
your choice and therefore it's your
responsibility and your burden and so
what is meant to be a burden shared by
the father and the mother equally has
become something that is just on the
mother now because the man says this is
a woman's issue this is your body this
is your choice so all of those women who
think okay now I'm pregnant some of them
will have an abortion okay many of them
don't want to have an abortion even if
it's not planned even if it's not wanted
many other women don't want to have an
abortion because they disagree with it
because they don't want to go through
the trauma of it whatever reason
and now they're faced with a man who
says it's your body it's your choice
this is your issue I'm having nothing to
do with it that is why I think
portraying it as a woman's only issue is
harmful to women themselves because this
was a job that is for a man and a woman
to do together in Partnership and why
wouldn't you want the like join like to
be strong together and get through
things together even if you don't want
to be with that man that man is still
the reason you are in this situation
exactly you have done it together it's
not his fault it's not your fault it's
together both of you have made that
decision both of you you should be
together through the decision and I
think if if a guy goes I don't want
anything to do with it
then it's a different situation but why
wouldn't you want to even just have that
kind of
extra bit of strength that you need to
get through this level up on that so so
one of the kind of arguments for
abortion originally was it's going to
get rid of single motherhood because we
have all these women who you know get
pregnant the man has abandoned them they
can just have an abortion now but what
actually happened is that when abortion
was legalized single motherhood
skyrocketed because of this dynamic
because men still got women pregnant
they got more women pregnant and then
they just pissed off and so what you
actually saw was so many more women get
into single motherhood which has
economic costs it has relational costs
it has cost of your time your resources
any cost you can imagine we know how
difficult Parenthood is or many of us do
I don't know exactly because I'm not one
yet
um but Parenthood is difficult and what
happened when abortion was legalized was
that all the cost of Parenthood went on
to mothers because the man said this is
your issue and so I think abortion
actually has made things worse and
there's good evidence for this you know
the the poverty in the United States was
going to be eliminated before 1970 it
was on a downward trend for decades and